Premiere is coming to valorant it's the
place where ordinary people like you and
me can go on to become the champions We
were always meant to be it's a simple
idea but it's gonna change the game
forever
[Music]
all right everyone before we get into
everything that Premiere has to offer I
want to give a huge shout out to our
partners over at Qualcomm Technologies
and the Snapdragon Elite Gaming Team
they've been helping us to explore
mobile Esports in the mind-blowing
technology that's the driving force
behind it we also got to go to San Diego
because of them and I got to go to my
first Dream hack which was super
exciting so if you want to learn more
about that make sure you check out our
episode of cracked on the explosive rise
of mobile Esports using the link below
spring has come and it brings new life
with it not only is shinsuke Nakamura
back in the ring we have new valern
content that changes the game and you
know I will always make it my business
to come on do not me talk about the
sweet nectar that is new shiny things
and valorant so what's new well valerund
premiere
Premiere is valerian's team-based
competitive system and the premier
Global open Beta launches April 25th
Premiere is the new in-game tournament
system that allows people who don't play
professional Valor and aka me you and
99.9 of the valorant community to get a
team together and compete just like the
pros do riot mentioned this all the way
back in 2022 but now it is coming for
everyone else with the beta test coming
April 25th they brought an alpha test to
Brazil in late 2022 emphasizing that it
was just a test and it comes to the rest
of the world just in time because ranked
sucks it is no secret that the ranked
competitive mode and valorined
especially for those in the higher elos
is not fun or rewarding in fact it is
just frustrating and unfair for everyone
there are so many people that should not
be there and there are so many people
that should be there but are horrible at
communicating and you don't want on your
team anyway so it's like it's just not a
fun experience like a good 30 of the
time and that's a bummer ranked got so
bad for the best of the best that tarek
rated Pro City to give him and his
fellow mechanical Gods a break from the
crypto throwers the ranked demons that
only know how to run it down the no mics
Etc I'm trying to achieve all the top
best players in any playing together in
customs so that we don't have to deal
with the drama of ranked and that the
level of play is higher that was a
Band-Aid solution and it couldn't
improve ranked for the vast majority of
players but premiere
very well do that here's how it works
Rye described it as valorin's team-based
competitive system lose that sounds a
lot like rape hold your horses and get
into it let's say you know your duo or
even your stack is destined for greater
things than the sewers are ranked where
stuff like this can happen
[Music]
personally I am always looking for a way
out of those situations that is what
Premiere is for is the premiere place
for team competition rather than ranked
your squad of five to seven can play
against similarly ranked teams after
your owner selects your Zone the owner
is a person who also enrolls your team
invites team members and creates that
fun little logo that everyone else will
see your Zone dictates your server and
your match schedule yes you have a match
schedule with map rotations the system
itself seems pretty robust you need SMS
verification a rank placement at any
point in time and account in good
standing and with a maximum two games a
week it really is like your own mini VCT
except you know with pincada unable to
miss a shot it's you out fragging and
outplaying the entire team but to be
clear this isn't just like have two
officials a week you have to qualify to
make it to the playoffs where you
compete in a bracket to make it all the
way to the top of your division so far
the only rewards that we know of are
player titles and cards which don't
sound too enticing but hey it's for the
glory remember that this could provide
the high quality competitive space that
ranked was failing to give it's like our
own little Pro City maybe it's just like
pleb City but for me it also brings back
a lot of the charm of the old Valerian
the open qualifiers are where Cinderella
stories can happen you watch your
favorite creators or the people you
didn't expect it to make it past their
first two games push their way through
an opening bracket with the introduction
of the partner program and the
challengers League it feels like to me
that we've just lost a lot of that charm
everything just feels the same same
people same comps everything just feels
a bit too safe which is great in its own
right and I admittedly tune in every
single time but some variety would be
nice I don't ask for much but now we are
the masters of our destiny the comps
that you've been begging your favorite
team to run well now you can run them on
your team instead of just watching the
VCT from the sidelines being relegated
to Twitch chat you're in the moment
you're in those clutch situations of
course you will still have rank to go to
you can play more than two games against
similarly ranked people but unless
you're in Pro City it's pretty much all
we have and it doesn't offer the same
feeling as a tournament with points and
playoffs does and is it going to fix
ranked no but it could make things
better I don't think it's the solution
but it's definitely a step to help us in
the right direction for sure like
giving people an incentive to want to
try hard in a team setting is going to
make players passively better but it
doesn't change the fact that there's
still going to be these people that are
kind of loners in solo queue in High ELO
ranks then they don't come and blame
everyone else and people are so excited
about this we get new characters and new
maps pretty often in the game but a new
competitive Arena that is pretty damn
different me and my roommates are making
a team for Premiere and that's going to
be super fun just because we're going to
be able to you know practice a little
bit together but also make some really
good content and just have a good time
competing at um you know much higher
level than we've been competing in
valorin now this is a beta which makes
me pretty happy considering Riot's
history with in-game competitive
tournament modes so Premiere sounds
great so far but will it be a success we
don't have to look too far for a clue
because Ryan has already implemented
something like this in League of Legends
Clash operates in a similar fashion to
the plans for Premier teams and
tournaments the tournaments themselves
are a lot smaller scale but the same
idea of casual players being able able
to compete is there but if you are a
league player you know that Clash didn't
exactly have a great start and hasn't
been smooth sailing since then in fact
it was and has been played with
technical issues that made the Lee
Community lose faith in the idea of it
and a bit of a sour taste in their
mouths and it's not like a one-time
thing there are multiple instances where
technical issues were big enough to
cause an official Riot response just
last year Raya was offering refunds when
things went awry good things like I
don't know the technical infrastructure
of a multi-million dollar company for
the sake of customer player experience
improved since then
yeah I hope so but just know valorant
player is that there is a precedent for
things like this not going perfectly so
proceed with optimistic caution but
let's say there is a perfect launch we
can set our own metas comps whatever the
structure of Vermeer has existed on the
outside for a little bit but now it is
accessible for everyone in game you
don't have to be a certain rank you just
have to want to play the real question
is
who are you playing with
I'm in Premiere as a team owner and sub
Elizabeth Sports to the Moon Esports
it's you know it's we're gonna Crush you
I'm sorry it's gonna happen I'm so sorry
you had to find out like this it's gonna
be great you're gonna lose and we're
gonna win
[Music]
foreign